Landon Donovan back and I guess didn't
want to be at home changing diapers
being around the newborn and you know
just got married and you've got to go
back to work Landon joining us now is
that how it went landed some like that
first came back I got a text from
someone they said I've heard a lot of
excuses to get out of dad duty but this
one a lot of how did this start dan well
first can I weigh in on a few things
okay yes you can lid um so I drink
almond milk but not the candy ass
vanilla flavored corn unsweetened time
okay and two if I were starting an NFL
franchise with one quarterback for seven
years it would be mr. Derek Carr okay
Raiders all right I'm fine with that one
of the way yeah loved Eric or I so how
did this come about so I was sitting
home happy waking up whenever I wanted
I'm doing whatever I wanted all day and
someone from the galaxy uh actually
staff I would text back and forth with
consistently over the last few years
along with some players and said hey you
know we just had some injuries when he
coming back and I've had that text a few
times from this particular person and it
was sort of you know always in jest but
I don't know something clicked and
something felt like maybe this was an
opportunity to come back and help and I
don't just felt right I don't really
have an explanation of it Matt how did
this go over with your wife yeah not
well I mean for you you know you talk to
a lot of athletes and it's it's a
glorious life what you see on TV on game
day but the rest of it's pretty
difficult and it's hard on families for
sure but you know to her credit she was
really
supportive and she said if it's
something that you want to do and that
makes sense then then great how long did
it take you to get in shape or are you
in shape no I'm not in shape and makes
you realize that it like to be in
athletics like really athletes shape you
forget how difficult that is and how how
much work goes into it so I mean I went
into a game last week I played for five
minutes I was absolutely exhausted and
this was at the end of the game when
everyone had been playing in 85 degree
heat so it's going to take a while but
I'm enjoying it it's been fun um what do
you think about it you think it's
probably a dumb idea mmmm no because you
could i I can't tell somebody when to
retire and we try to do that as guys get
older than we were always saying oh how
much longer you going to do this when
are you going to retire David Ortiz
Peyton Manning I it's up to you you have
to live with it not me and I think once
you put it to bed then you know can you
keep it there and I think it's really
hard because there's urges that you have
and there's you guys are such you know
creatures a habit that you're used to
doing certain things at certain times of
the year and it probably hit you it's
like wow they're playing I'm not and
then all of a sudden you get that idea
or somebody puts it in your head and
then you convince yourself so i would i
would not begrudge you may tell you yeah
you're not gonna you probably won't
believe this and you'll think it's BS
but I said sitting home the last two
years I have had zero desire to go run
around a soccer field and I in fact I
don't play soccer anymore at all at home
I play tennis I go workout I run but I
don't play soccer anymore it's just not
you know that's not what what excites me
anymore but this opportunity seemed like
it was two things and again I heard you
talk about it earlier sort of in jest
but one was a chance to help the team
and I felt like this was a opportunity
that could help team but to
I know my son's only eight months old
and he's not gonna remember anything but
I do want to have memories with him on
the field with me and and have something
to show him one day so I mean you know
maybe 13 he said that I don't care about
that crap why'd you do that that was
done but you know maybe doesn't maybe
appreciate so why did you pick number 26
that's the day my son was born and they
wouldn't give me number 10 back so I
kind of got screwed if you didn't have a
sudden in down if you didn't have a son
would you come back well that's a good
question uh no no I would not have how
are you good well huh you believe me now
yeah but I don't begrudge you I mean
you're you're lucky to be able to have
this opportunity because they're guys
who want to come back there guys you
want to play they don't have the
opportunity but at age 32 when you said
and I didn't know if what happened at
the World Cup when you were left off the
roster that that sort of soured you on
the sport or your place or do I want to
continue to do this I I don't know what
did that have any impact on you not
making the world cup team with the first
retirement it didn't it didn't make my
decision for me I certainly didn't help
me want to keep playing I had actually
made up my mind beginning of that year
before the world cup thing happened so I
was you know unless something crazy
happened I was done but what's happened
in two years you know come back and
started training my body now feels young
again I'm excited again to be around it
and and maybe just having a break was
important you know and I was very
fortunate not to have any major injuries
while I was playing but along with that
means you don't get a lot of breaks
right so you're constantly practicing
you're constantly playing so it just
kind of wore me out and you know you
talk like barry sanders when he was just
amused done with it and maybe if he had
had a year to break you know maybe what
I felt differently here Big Papi talk
about how he's just done he's just
physically done and he's beat up and
maybe having a break is good so I feel
rejuvenated and refreshed and I don't
know maybe i'll suck when i go outside
but it'll be it'll be enjoyable and
helps i can help well you might enjoy it
more now than you did before because
before you didn't have that break and
really understand what you love about it
and i think that that perspective has
helped you where is your just going out
there and I comes with honest right yeah
you're right no I mean if you took a few
years away from your show would you
appreciate it more I'm trying to retire
Landon they keep calling me back yeah
okay I have a question okay someone says
uh Dan you're fired from the DP show
yeah and you're going to start up a new
station yeah and you're going to start
up a new show but you can only take one
of the debts who are you taking I think
I've answered it but i think i have
different answers at different times
when i'm asked I i think the
infrastructure I would want seton but
the day to day I would want Paulie so I
I'm sort of backing I'm backing out it
did Paulie give you that question to see
what I thought of Pauly well I was
curious always wondered i think a lot of
your fans always wondered that I I
dislike you know everyone says all their
kids are the same and I love them all
the same like we all know no like one
kid definitely has preference over
others you know yeah so I was Paris um I
think Seton with just building it but
Paulie with actually doing it that
that's where I would started depending
on you know what I needed to do if I
needed infrastructure if I didn't then
you know be Paulie doing day-to-day but
to build it I would need Seton to start
with okay Holly I actually we haven't
talked about what did you think about
this whole thing about me coming back
I'm curious um I I was pretty surprised
because you seemed I was very surprised
because you seemed really comfortable
the past two years when we've talked and
you didn't seem at all like you would
talk about sometimes you and I would
text back and forth and you say I like
watching it I don't really want to get
back out there but the Sun thing to me I
think changes everything when I
get Michael Phelps and his son there and
I think I don't have a son but i think
if i had a son I'd want my son to see me
perform my sport that I worked my life
at and like Jeff Gordon did the same he
extended his career so his son could see
him so went the Sun part explained it
all in about two seconds for me right
that's why you think Phelps was home
again absolutely yeah I don't know I
don't see it I don't sit but yeah I'm
probably I'm in the minority of that
with fells I thought he would come back
this time around because he was too
young and there was too much money there
with sponsorship I don't know if you say
well his son's gonna be five at the time
and maybe he's gonna he could swim for
him but if USA soccer calls you I don't
know you're gonna have that are you
taking the phone call from your Jurgen
Klinsmann I'm gonna answer you in a sec
but you know what i like about your
showed in so when we do these you know i
was looking at the mall mark wahlberg
interview earlier and her and his
daughter was like what this shows great
and it's fun usually if i'm listening to
radio show and they have an athlete on
i'll change it because you just get this
sort of boring same old answers that you
already know are coming but you asked
questions that make us uncomfortable so
it makes for good radio so now to answer
your question if USA soccer called and
said what would you like to help us with
the team in some way anyway would you be
part of the experience if I felt if I
felt I could actually help and
contribute then yeah of course that's I
mean that's a million miles who have
i've played a total of like 20 minutes
now in two years but what if you're ghen
Klinsmann wanted you to be part of the
coaching stead
again if I felt I was able to contribute
i would consider it why would you want
me to say I know I was thinking you
would say no way in hell but say it in
German that would be that'd be a great
response well why not jurgen klinsmann
um you know what you did a great job
getting out of the house not many of us
can use that excuse you're an
inspiration for all the dads who would
like to get out of the house so they
don't have to change diapers well done
well done uh congratulate let's just
talk about really quickly did she really
say Carson Wentz would be as quarterback
yes he did you see with that crispy was
that in jest or was it there was a
perfectly serious pic I'm looking back I
can understand why someone would say Cam
Newton or Russell Wilson or Andrew Luck
but Carson Wentz just brought back some
Manning memories the way with control
that offense Monday night against okay
all right you know yeah you're that guy
on Twitter like you have one good game
he's the best in the world that's me
well he had great things to say about
you on Twitter of those five minutes
that you played for its he was saying
you were the greatest of soccer player
in the world forget Neymar and
everything everybody else yeah Messi and
well just stop stop watching now so we
get uglier I'll go get in shape all
right all right good thank you thats
Landon Donovan the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience